what are we gonna do today hiking  obviously I'm never acting yeah you are  I'm not going yes you are  no I don't like to go ahead liking no  I'm not going hiking you always make me  leave happy birthday thank you I'm so  excited about tonight  I forgot forgot why make your  reservation this goes back to not  valuing my time good let's get a selfie  you all the people okay wait my eyes are  burning here you hold a sunlight that  way maybe Martin's definitely can't  afford - what about sugar fish that's up  why do we go on this vacation now we  can't even afford to eat look so nice  thank you I love that necklace curly so  much your mom good yeah let's take a  picture we look good today oh we look so  cute way to go  [Music]  always